conocido por su sombrero con cuernos y
apodado como el chamán qua non' por la
teoría de la conspiración de extrema
derecha que apoya una que presenta a
donald trump como salvador y a los
dirigentes demócratas como una cábala
satánica jacov chang lee de 34 años fue
uno de los primeros manifestantes en
entrar al capitolio el 6 de enero y se
convirtió en una de las caras más
reconocidas entre los seguidores de
trump que asaltaron el capitolio tras un
discurso del entonces presidente en el
que reclamaba sin fundamentos que perdió
la elección como resultado de un fraude
electoral
este año los demócratas llevaron a cabo
el robo electoral más descarado y
escandaloso y nunca existió nada como
esto es un auténtico robo en la historia
estadounidense
se pierde el merkén es ser barinas sin
camiseta y lanza en mano chance lee
entró en la cámara del senado mientras
el entonces vice presidente mike pence
presidía el orden del día cuatro
personas murieron por la violencia
desatada el 6 de enero y más de 100
policías resultaron 2 un oficial de la
policía del capitolio atacado por los
manifestantes falleció también al día
siguiente la cámara de representantes
inició un proceso de destitución
impeachment contra donald trump por
incitar a la revuelta si bien fue
absuelto posteriormente en el senado
charly cuya imagen se volvió viral en
redes sociales fue detenido sin fianza
tras su arresto en enero en septiembre
se declaró culpable de un único cargo
obstrucción a una sesión del congreso
apuntó estar decepcionado con donald
trump por no haberle insultado antes de
salir de la casa blanca' en su detención
fue diagnosticado con esquizofrenia
transitoria desorden bipolar depresión y
ansiedad su sentencia a 41 meses de
prisión llega el mismo día que scott
ferland ciudadano de new yersey recibió
la misma sentencia por su participación
en la revuelta hay cerca de 700 casos
criminales ligados al asalto al
capitolio